no in gunam aquiline el mundo que pueda
ser o idea todo dispositivo console
alambre solamente son Aya's otra vez sa
conocimiento ancestral de los Peggy
doses a dedication que la gran hacer
esto sister Cuba's an complex seed
hombre es Frank trail rental son medico
carry on oo pediatric intensivist ax y
me derecho a fabric are dispositive O's
médicos Bratsk repair prepper Dada's
caleca gracias a estos dispositivo Skoda
musk you God hasta un Sesenta por ciento
las enfermedades scene habla de esto es
Pacifica Avanza porous protector Yaga
dawn s tell defecto cardiac o te reckon
Segura en este lugar CFL expect o kahi
aho yo Michael trabajar en bois Liddy
tenía la tecnología no tenia mackey y
las personas on de niro a minium pedido
estan despues tose haddad rapini horas
que vienen de nosotros so Negara
11 la capacidad hacer el take en su
sangha s Sesenta setenta por ciento de
los bolivianos viene de estas personas a
visionary a-- capability como cheetahmen
SOC hora en el comienzo sido pacient a
nuestros
Nero who knows pacientes que no mo mo
Grados tratar sus hijos less initiative
Collison Sione innocent ahaha no Soto yo
me llamo Tony cut biddable for Yosemite
hey Dora me momma mean to know the hair
Linea nosotros que temos less
dispositivo Zahid on a salver me de los
pequeños es como tres horas in los
grandes his major is the minister he
goes to Table two Justinian Karina moral
Kishida son Mazda steel Puente me
pacientes que hemos tratado si el
conocimiento y lack system at associate
a trellis engineer Mahavira dial on
Tedesco casita de pollution SOT specific
Oh
Ramez el mozo que esto specky doses
Australis full token technology ax
expensive angle Nino's para me soon
Milano
[Music]
my goal is to get every single single
woman carrying around condoms just as
they carry around everything else it's
like a no-brainer
I always joke like people take selfies
with condom
[Music]
I'm Nika Hollander and I'm the
co-founder of sustain which is a brand
of all-natural sexual wellness products
marketed to women only 19 percent of
single sexually active women use condoms
regularly and one in four college
freshmen actually gets an STD during her
first year at school this is a crisis
and this is the subject that isn't being
talked about because when you think
about condoms and lubricants these are
products that can be seen as taboo women
are extremely uncomfortable buying and
carrying condoms when I go to my peers
and the people that I know they're the
worst offenders we're trying to rebrand
it a little bit and completely empower
women to take control of their sexual
health with much better product most
lubricants out there contain parabens
and klitz uhrin and petroleum and
silicones our products have none of
those things
they're aloe and water based it's the
only Fairtrade certified terse magine
free condom on the market in the US we
are starting a conversation that needs
to be had I spend a lot of time talking
to consumers about why they not only
need to be using our products but also
why they should be jacuzzis comics in
general you should never feel ashamed
for wanting to or having sex but the
reality is you're out there for you and
you need to protect yourself nobody else
is going to
c-sections are the most common major
surgery performed on human beings over
basically one generation of moms the
c-section rate has gone up by 500%
problem is that your number one risk for
having a c-section might be which
hospital you go to that's what wakes me
up in the morning Emile Shaw an
obstetrician over at Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical Center I'm an
assistant professor at Harvard Medical
School and I'm part of the core faculty
here at Ariadne labs a lot of people
don't realize the full magnitude of the
problem with c-sections basically in the
late 1960s early 1970s c-section rates
were about 5% and then all of a sudden
the c-section rate starts to skyrocket
not just increased but skyrocket so
before the end of the century when a
c-section rate goes up to one and three
and we don't really have a great idea
why this is happening as a surgeon
myself it's hard to believe that one in
three human beings needs major surgery
to be born but that's sort of where we
are right now and the consequences are
significant so things like severe
infection hemorrhage organ injury in
addition to five billion dollars
spending annually we're talking
something like 20,000 major avoidable
surgical complications we're seeing from
c-sections we didn't need to do in the
first place I was really puzzled when I
first started this job thinking like
what can we possibly do about this
epidemiologist economist policymakers
lots of people have been thinking about
this for a long time the clue for me was
the fact that cross-country c-section
rates vary from seven percent to 70
percent by hospital
this hospital performance is so uneven
and it's not explained by patient risk
or patient preference that means the
hospital itself could be a risk factor
all of our projects right now are
actually trying to figure out what makes
possible a different from hospital B
what we've seen is that oftentimes the
labor floors and kind of like a almost
forgotten about corner and it just
doesn't get a lot of investment or
attention from the hospital when we
visit a bunch of different hospitals we
realize that they're laid out very
differently and that might matter for
example there are no rules for how many
labor floor rooms you should have based
on the amount of patients that you see
the place that does twice as many
deliveries also does way more c-sections
the only way that's possible is if
they're moving people through much
faster almost all labor floors seem
really tight on resources so the idea is
when you have a huge surge in patient
volume how do you flexibly recruit more
rooms how do you bring in more staff you
report c-section rates back to your
doctors look I have no idea what my
c-section rate is until somebody tells
me you know we're testing the hypothesis
that management matters in childbirth
just the way it matters in every other
industry we're starting to parse
differences among c-section so rather
than looking at all c-sections
altogether we're trying to just take the
lowest risk women can focus on their
c-section me
we need to start to do that two things
happen insurance companies start to pay
attention and then just women start to
pay attention and I actually think this
is an area where women's views on this
are probably going to be the driving
force behind the change
there's really no other moment in
people's life where they're so
discerning as when they become pregnant
[Music]
I think the homeless in general just
feel that they've been completely
forgotten by society that nobody cares
about them nobody cares if they wake up
tomorrow they might even feel like they
think that people hope that they don't
wake up tomorrow and I didn't think that
anybody should have to feel like that so
I decided that when I became a PA that I
wanted to focus on on the homeless
population
[Music]
so street medicine is really a program
that was born out of the idea that
everybody matters we see that there are
certain segments of the population that
just don't access health care the way
everybody else does
[Music]
because Allentown is a relatively small
city it is still surrounded by woods so
most of the homeless you're not going to
see sleeping outside on the street so
they go live in the woods and pence so
that's usually where we have to go to
find our patience I have a backpack with
over 20 medications we have an EKG
machine we do point-of-care testing or
we can get different bloodwork the whole
idea is to deliver quality care on-site
in a place where the patient feels
comfortable you still have that inhaler
Mike yeah how often are you using a 1 a
2 over 68 everything we do is completely
free we provide free medications free
labs free diagnostic studies so they
don't need insurance and we have the
same incredible people that see them all
the time they get to know us and trust
us and we're lucky enough that they
allow us to help them to just prove
normal doing this job can be extremely
difficult you just see things that are
really hard to see and and sometimes
feel helpless but one of the things that
I always try to do is just try and
completely forget myself in it to
remember that this is not about me at
all it's just about the patients it
doesn't matter if I'm tired it doesn't
matter if I'm frustrated with trying to
help somebody it just doesn't matter
about me it matters about them so I try
and focus on them and their needs
as long as prosthesis have been around
people have been really focusing on
making it look like a hand and move like
a hand but a hand is not just a grab a
hand is a touch
this touch that engages you if the world
is touched that engages you with people
a prosthesis without touch is a tool by
giving touch we're giving back a hand I
[Music]
worked in a factory setting before I
lost my arm I was doing some cleaning
under out from underneath the shredder
type machine and I'm grab material that
was in my hand and pulled my hand into
the machine I didn't think that I'd ever
have the sensation of touch or anything
back again and then my prosthetics told
me about the research program up here in
Cleveland they hope to be able to give
me the sense of touch the research that
we've been doing is reconnecting the man
to the machine basically learning how to
take what the prosthesis feels and
translates that the person using it
feels it the brain to feel touch as
being their actual hand it's really
important that we activate or stimulate
the wires that the brain always used to
get from the hand
what we do is we implant cuff electrodes
and then we apply really tiny amounts of
current that activate those wires and
that information then goes to the brain
so we've been learning how to place this
information on that nerve so the brain
thinks it's his hand they can feel not
just buzzing but also a touch of
pressure looks like we're putting a
finger on their hand and in fact we've
been able to see that intensity of the
artificial stimulation
mimics being tight and soft big block
the first time they put sensation on
everything it was just incredible it was
like wow could actually feel an area in
my hand a certain area tingling and
vibrations and stuff small soft blocks I
said just an incredible feeling
bringing the prosthetic home with the
sensory hand on it and being able to
feel and everything's changed life
considerably it's little things that
people take for granted
brushing teeth to be able to hold the
toothpaste and be able to squeeze and
tell how hard I'm squeezing this they
don't squeeze and go every place it
makes it a lot easier we're at the point
where subjects can use their prosthesis
at home they can add sensation while
they're at home it makes them two-handed
again it brings back their hand and
makes them whole
[Music]
when a patient first comes to our office
they feel a little self-conscious about
the way they look or they want look
people I die people always think I'm
just doing this for cosmetic reasons it
actually is the restoration of a person
I'm an ocularist that is sewing that
fits and fabricates artificial eyes for
people during the surgery to remove your
ID the doctors place an implant in the
muscle cone so we fit a concave convex
shape that sits like a contact lens on
the implant it is an art form we do
everything by hand first we take an
impression this gives us an imprint of
the exact structures behind the eyelids
painting is very challenging
everything starts from a black disc and
everything is painted on top of that
it's very difficult to match the iris
color no two people have the same color
so we'll sit there with a paintbrush and
we'll paint different structures dots
dashes striations overlay that with
different hues or different saturations
of color to give it a three-dimensional
effect that we see in people's natural
eyes part of what makes it look natural
is to have the sparkle in your eye we do
that with fine polishing and fine tuning
the curves of the artificial eye the
part I most like about fabricating a
prosthesis is when I finished it and I
look at it and I see the illusion that I
just created when somebody loses their
eye sometimes they feel like they've
lost part of their self being we make
them feel whole again and confident to
take on the world
[Music]
you
[Music]